and we've come up with a design that
puts 12,000 people in one building for
months before he died in 2011 Steve Jobs
made his final public appearance
pitching apple's new campus which opened
this year central to his vision was
turning existing parking lots into a
green landscape the overall feeling of
the place is going to be a zillion times
better than it is now with all the
asphalt so we'd like to plant a lot of
trees including some apricot orchards
but jobs didn't mention that the new
parking structure on campus would have
more floor space than the office
building that's because it wasn't
apple's plan the decision came from the
city of Cupertino which demanded 11,000
parking spots for the campus but
Cupertino is hardly unique it's
estimated that in America there are
eight parking spots for every car
covering up to 30 percent of our cities
and collectively taking up about as much
space as the state of West Virginia the
more parking we have the more were able
to drive so the rules that manage our
parking not only influence the way we
move around but also shape our urban
landscapes
[Music]
if you look at pictures of the American
cities around 1920 and 1930 all of the
curbs are just completely filled with
parked cars and they couldn't use prices
to manage to ban because the parking
meter wasn't even invented until 1935
this is Donald chute an urban planning
professor at University of California
Los Angeles whose specialty is parking
as cars filled cities in the early 20th
century two inventions came to dominate
parking management throughout the United
States the first was the parking meter
the meter manufacturers popularized the
parking meter so they offered them free
to cities and they kept the revenue
until the meter was paid for at about
six months and then the city got all the
revenue they offered to install about
one side of the street only so people
could see you how it worked on one side
and how it worked on the other at the
same time the parking meter was invented
cities invented the idea of off street
parking but partners off street parking
requirements also known as mandatory
parking minimums are the second
invention and though you may not be
aware of them most of the parking lots
you're used to exist because of these
rules in the background look at any
place from the air at a suburban place
from the air you'll see an awful lot of
land taking up for parking and most
people don't know why it's our policy
that we require our cities to be built
with a lot of partner with
suburbanization after World War two
off street parking requirements became
popular with city governments they
forced developers to include parking for
their new buildings which created a huge
supply of parking at no cost to the city
wall street parking requirements really
spread throughout the United States
faster than almost any other urban
planning invention lay arose partly
because the lack of management
on street parking if you can't manage
the on-street parking properly you need
off street parking requirements or
everybody will say how did you let this
building be built brothers don't f
Barker a typical requirement looks like
this for every 1000 square feet of new
building there has to be a set number of
parking spots which varies by land use
you have to have a parking spaces per
something that could be the number of
spaces per bassinet in that hospital or
per holes at a golf course or for a
thousand gallons of water at a swimming
pool
well the honest ones is for a funeral
home because that strobes up no parking
spaces per what an average parking spot
requires about 330 square feet which
includes car storage and empty space
allowing the car to move in and out and
for doors to open that means if a policy
requires three spots per thousand square
feet the parking lot needs to be the
size of the building and many parking
requirements need more spots a
restaurant may need 10 spots per
thousand square feet making the parking
lot over 3 times larger than the
restaurant planners don't have any
training in how to set them really no
way to say how much parking every
building needs so there's a
pseudoscience that has grown off it's
like like like bloodletting you know
which was a major form of medical
treatment for a couple thousand years
and they look just like parking enormous
today building parking is expensive
especially when it involves a large
construction project we pay for the free
bar that we demand in every role we have
a life others that as a driver as a
taxpayer
as a resident as a shopper and just
because you paid nothing at the parking
lot at the grocery store doesn't mean
the cost goes away it's still there it's
just that the driver isn't paying for
developers who don't comply with parking
requirements paid tens of thousands of
dollars in fees for every spot that they
don't include a lot of times these costs
prohibit new development this is a most
valuable land holder land is expensive
for housing but it's free for partner
and you wonder why we have a problem
parking requirements often result in
more parking space than building space
pushing buildings further apart from
each other making it harder to walk and
encouraging more driving many of the
dense cities that we love like Paris or
Washington DC or Amsterdam or New York
wouldn't look like this with parking
requirements these arbitrary rules
continue to shape the growth of our
cities and increase traffic congestion
but the excessive amount of land
dedicated to parking is able to be
repurposed we have terrific opportunity
to convert underused parking lots into
housing where people want to live but
the upside is that we have a lot of
benefits to to reap from changing our
policies
well to Marlon 800-page book down into
three bullet points I have three basic
recommendations remove Wall Street Park
/ Tarkas charge the right price for
on-street parking clownfish I mean the
lowest price the city can charge and
still have one or two open spaces on
every block so nobody can say there's a
shortage apart in order to reach that
price you have to vary it by location
and time of day but once you've done
that and make it politically popular and
spend the revenue on public services on
the metered streets
well I'm worn out